from Yahoo Covington post Jenna Ellis
mocked for invoking God after getting
indicted well you know let her invoke
whatever she wants to invoke she tweeted
the Democrats and the Fulton County D.A
are criminalizing the practice of law I
am resolved to trust the Lord and I will
simply continue to honor praise and
serve him I am deeply appreciative of
all my friends who have reached out
offering encouragement and support Jenna
Ellis was a lawyer for Trump now she's
getting roasted by Trump's most Ardent
supporters we've got this tweet from
Laura Loomer professional liar and Trump
backstabber John Alice was indicted last
night for the last several months she
has been attacking Donald Trump online
with Team DeSantis she betrayed Donald
Trump I personally think she
intentionally sabotaged him because I
can't fathom anyone can be as stupid as
she is and decided to support Rhonda
Sanders instead she's been attacking
Trump online for having his pack pay his
legal fees even though his supporters
are more than happy to donate to the
cause Jenna has called Trump supporters
grifters and she's been retweeting other
Descent of supporters who attacked
Donald Trump now she is crying online
begging Trump supporters to donate to
her legal defense fund la War goes on
and calls her vile and a liar
but I do think it's it's really
interesting
I'm not going to say I can speak for
Jenna Ellis
personally specifically I have no idea
but there are many people
who hey go look at their uh their
YouTube videos go look at things they
said when they were guests on TV shows
who advocated for action on January 6
who advocated for Donald Trump's legal
uh actions who advocated for alternate
slates of electors and all of these
things directly demanding it be done
saying that people should occupy or
people should do this that are otherwise
how long do you think until Democrats in
various jurisdictions start going after
them saying that they were inciting and
encouraging and those that were in
communication with Donald Trump were
acting in furtherance of the conspiracy
I don't well my thought is
it's tough to tell but that what they
want is Donald Trump to not be president
and for there to be order across the
United States so if they start
persecuting the population I think that
will serve as a breakdown of order I I
don't know how far you know like when
you get what you want you don't want to
take any more than that you got enough
they're saying that they fear they could
go too far yes
I'm not I'm not so sure I don't care how
far they go we have not seen an instance
of de-escalation yeah like I was just
gonna say like where's the off ramp what
what's the offering what is the the
thing that makes someone say we don't
escalate to the next obvious level
federal law enforcement raided the home
of some woman in Alaska because she
looked like another woman who went
looked like another woman who went into
the capital if they are willing to lock
there's a man locked up right now it's
been two two and a half years without
charge or trial
because he won't disavow Donald Trump
he's in DC in in prison if they're
willing to do that to random people
are you saying that they would just
decide like well this guy's got a
million followers on on you know Twitter
or whatever and he was telling people to
go there and engage in this Behavior you
think they're going to ignore Alex Jones
well if random Alex Jones was leading
one of the rallies outside the Capitol
building but he said don't go in but
they're not they don't care right well
they they they're not doing it to random
necessarily random people the guy was at
chance six that's why his and the woman
they thought she was a chance it'll be
the people with the wrong person no but
they have that could be random
they have done random I I I I I believe
I don't know they have knock on it it's
not random it's always politically
motivated there's always people with the
wrong political opinion so it's not
random no right so yeah
people who are into January 6th correct
yeah I have heard that they have gone to
people's homes that weren't even at Gen
6 and that's to your point what if I did
a podcast two years ago and I said yeah
I really don't care what happened on
January 6th like sure it was fine they
can just come to you and come knock on
your door and say Hey you because you
agreed with what happened on j6 we're
we're taking you in well I think more
likely they're going to go to the
individuals that pre-january 6 who are
telling people to go there
and uh there are a lot of quotes that I
won't say but there were people who were
advocating for direct action at the
Capitol on these like now these people
were never there right but they're going
to say that they were inciting
insurrection
more importantly there are high profile
personalities who are in direct
communication with Trump and his legal
team and then went on TV or YouTube or
whatever and said either as guests or
hosts this is the plan this is what
they're doing it's totally legal and
everyone should support them for it
they're gonna say that person was part
of the conspiracy
Trump trump told them we need to build
support use your platform to encourage
everyone to help us and they're going to
save us conspiracy there might be people
that wanted a march on the Capitol and a
Siege of the capital and then a
prevention of the legal process there
might be people that did that but a lot
of those people were just there in that
emergent phenomenon of mob mentality
took over a lot of people were waved in
by cops I've heard cops are taking
selfies with people yeah it wasn't like
everyone went there to overthrow the
government that's not what happened a
lot of people got wrapped up in this and
I don't even know if Donald Trump wanted
to overthrow the government I don't know
this is the point right now if they're
willing to go after some 60 year old
dude who walked around outside and
didn't even go in the building there are
people who are criminally charged who
never entered the building but they were
on the grounds and that's that's good
enough if they're gonna go after them
yeah they went to the extent where they
went to a woman's house in Alaska and
she wasn't even in the building and
raided her home she she was actually in
Washington though she was in Washington
at like Trump's at the Trump speech or
whatever but she never went in the
Capitol building she looked like someone
she's like a similar coat so they rated
her house well there's people that were
saying that there were hot dog vendors
there like there were people that were
playing music they went for people that
were on the outskirts of all of this
that was going on like
if you were in a picture oh yeah we know
that we we see that person we're gonna
go ahead and you're arrested we're
closing your bank account down we're
doing this doing that locking you up
whatever whatever they did to him I have
no idea I wasn't there but I will say
this as an influencer online
was I asked by followers hey are you
going to go I didn't think it was going
to go that way I thought it was going to
go like a totally different way where
like we were going to get hurt because
people didn't like Trump supporters so I
was like I'm good on this one I would
recommend you guys don't go right
because maybe we'll get hurt but they
could go after all the little guys like
myself at the time that might have been
like go there let's go there let's let's
it's just crazy I think it's going to be
bigger personalities because as we move
into 2024 their goal is to silence
anyone who would provide public support
for Trump yeah so first they go for his
legal team anybody who helped him many
of the j6ers can't get lawyers
right then they're going to Target
moderate to large personalities who are
in the Trump periphery who are
advocating for and supporting Trump's
presidency because they want to hurt
that they want people to fear supporting
Trump fear and there are a lot of people
who used to be the most Ardent Trump
supporters who turned on a dime and are
now saying Trump's a grifter and a con
man into Santa says the light in the way
and I just think that's very very funny
because I think I've I've these people
posted YouTube videos
you know where they were very very on
board with Trump and now all of a sudden
they're panicking right I think I think
they started to get scared interesting
you know I've I've heard I've there's
background there's background talk and I
try to avoid saying stuff like this but
I'm sure most of you who are listening
I've heard something to this effect that
people believe Ron DeSantis is a deep
state plant
and it's a little bit of an exaggeration
Donald Trump supported Ronda Sanders so
whatever but there are people who
believe that DeSantis is supported by
Deep State Elements by these these you
know uniparty fundraisers
so that he can be the safe landing for
Trump supporters and off ramp for them
they want Total Control the uni party
will take control Donald Trump is an
anomalous how do you get people to stop
supporting Trump and support someone
who's your controlled opposition
Rhonda santis does all the culture wore
stuff right floor looks really good but
then when Trump comes back Ron can't
manage the campaign and then he fumbles
but there are a lot of people and who
who believe that and again I'm not
saying that's true I'm saying that when
you like backdoor private conversations
with people involved in politics their
attitude is you see the people who begin
funding Ron DeSantis and it looks like
they're hoping he can be more
controllable than Trump and Trump
supporters will back him well the only
way you're going to get a trump
supporter to not support Trump is do all
this other stuff that we're talking
about to him
when you because then you won't have a
choice if he's not on the ticket right
so then you're gonna go then by default
then you would go for someone like
DeSantis Trump isn't going to lose his
current supporters he never will nothing
he can
sorry but he can skin a cat online and
people will have excuses for why he did
that and they're still going to vote for
him his base is strong in my opinion
there are yeah and the only way you're
gonna get though sorry but the only way
you're gonna get I mean I love him like
I love what he did for the country so
for me I never wavered from that I'm a
Floridian so I think Rhonda Santos needs
to fix what hurricane Ian did to us last
year before he starts running around the
country doing all this presidential
stuff but you have to get rid of trump
somehow in order for his supporters to
not have him to vote for there are
instances of people that are like well
vivek's younger smarter faster and he
wants to continue what some of the
policies Trump was doing I'm going with
the younger smarter candidate there are
some people I think you're right for the
most part yeah the people that are
emotionally invested in a human tend to
stay emotionally invested in the human I
personally serve a function I serve the
function of President and I don't care
what person it is at the moment I want
the best candidate right
policy policy Personnel temperament
policy things like that temperament's a
big part of it yeah the big part of
where Trump's misgivings is that people
don't like him that he's alienated and
insulted so many people that behind the
scenes are like you know get rid of that
guy he's an like we don't want
that same thing what happened to soccer
I'm not going to bring up Socrates all
night but that's the same thing Socrates
brilliant man poor social skills pissed
off too many people in high up positions
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time